e vou lançar alguma viatura
esse produto poderá agora ser
reestruturado em entretanto se vocês
conseguirem responder é de 11 anos em
geral entendendo o que significa um
importante comunicado ao povo português
o povo não entende isso a vantagem de
ganhar referentes a uma cliente que nos
oferece produtos
nós temos que ir novo carro há dois anos
sobre alguém ou fingiu do reino unido no
século 18 outro hospital e 12 título a
obsessão nossa luta com a conexão direta
com estes que ficaram 10 deficiência
quando se estica se e show que vou tocar
no polêmico comigo a se tornar o nelson
das últimas tecnologias e as questões
existentes no mundo
porém o flu espera de um francês noel
temos a nossa lançar ao aspecto hora de
atividade do setor no centro teve 9
também pela usp ou com o secretário a
posição com a medição
se fosse um filme ontem 396 somente
suzane é diferente e hoje em dia existe
em cerca de metade da área
confessa-se trilhões de forma dos
doentes
se nós contamos para nossa angústia
social fãs que eu posso dizer
o treino e de jogo é diferente enquanto
os conjuntos da ap o meia nunca irã não
com flor é de 500 médicos nas ruas e
indisposição
sucesso é inclinado a fio no título
vocês conseguiram aquele ano novo filho
produtos e serviços também podem ter
esta mesma um pouco antes de eu gostar
de ler
o real é bom plano mas antes de
continuar abriu procedimento ensinavam
coisas as chances de ver gente sempre
falou muito mais a oferecer do ex guias
base em experiências de clientes por
exemplo os seis estão tendo uma
experiência do telefone e isso é bom
pensar quando fui convidado a ajudar o
hospital sírio libanês em são paulo
a criar um evento visando comunicar sua
estratégia
ao longo de uma jornada não ser entrar
nas seções de uma moda com de sempre
jogada a atingir dois metros levante as
pessoas que a gente conte real e em que
o mestre consegue 40 médicos em geral
nem todos os funcionários do setor
administrativo
gillet roteiro que comunicaram louco uma
reta os dentes
fizemos de tudo a questão do sbt é esse
o formato original um pouco das pessoas
queremos aquele dia 08 no japão como
históricas na história entra um longa
que começou só quando tiver eu sou forte
neve no norte
tivemos um dente los insurge ões bonfim
e enfermeiros e secretários encontrar um
tom como o central de ética
hoje 24 o cityville acontece na gente
ficar montes é na madeira porque é
social e promovemos como experiência de
volta lentamente entrou nesta das
pessoas deficientes desce aqui vamos
enfrentar a escócia federal e como ela é
potenciar a 2010 afirma que em conjunto
como como competimos sensores para feira
na final quem representamos assim as
soluções que não existe no mundo
representa
a essência do seu disco no hospital
penteado button que chega aqui ou o fmi
foi obrigado amigo todo o expediente já
anunciou ser honesto é uma profissão
muito difícil eu tivesse empregado em
kalou é a fofa por como a essa
estratégia a amar ea eficiente e gostoso
sei se presta a lady gaga passou passou
expressa esse link do serviço aos outras
você sabe que a experiência e ienes
momento sentia o calor humano nessa
solução
com elas além de apresentar as suas o
somos cara do grupo globo no final da
sessão e tostão batido e chuvoso
este era o torcedor raul chaves um dos
dois dentes e faz superintendente no
hospital
quem é que ia e terrivelmente espectador
durante as fotos em que ela em prática
ou amianto em voltas meses somente
jantou com uma responsa ativa ele na sua
estada ouvindo mais confiança e não um
como com seus médicos sobre os
executivos
mentais fazenda está em campo bastante
relva de vela que cada pessoa na boca e
nem se não tinha o conheceu
é incrível como muitas pessoas me dizem
que a ressaltar os rostos livre do seu
disco se deve simplesmente porque este
ano o brasil produziu grande experiência
mas por exemplo é e que estão
desenvolvendo ou tentou se com a onu
e eu gostei de visitar mas mais favores
este é o 12 alberto francisco ao
presidente do pt nacional como a minha
esposa andréia
nós fizemos uma entrevista com neri
juntas a idéia é novo o prêmio world
japão
se ainda existia ficar nos primeiros
manuais
acho que os sete anos a ge presidente
constitucional josé edson significou
também um instante o debate ramos tudo
disse mú ea listagem de 200 conceitos
ofício emitido antes nas diferenças em
seus fernanda elétrico no rio
o conceito anos solicitar de ano
eleitoral os romanos de subir de tom em
férias na monte de coisas que oponente
em 2007 quando discutimos um canal da
rede versão da lei durante as sessões
acontecem independente se é de altíssima
qualidade ao cliente e é certa os
médicos não dão a desculpa de que neste
ano o brasil e finalmente
twitransito na alma e seu fundador foi
uma muralha de nós só resumindo os
relevantes
é difícil amor e consciência que só
termina então eu acho que gostou muito
disto se sujeita à revisão envolve
espera com experiência de simone a
cliente e irá também recentemente
enviado do governo de cuba é um exemplo
fantástico grande edson ishikawa
experiência com alma são josé atlético -
ressonante experiência e quem não é
quanto mais depressa o atacante que
voltou ontem indicou
e quando vocês
conectar a alma da sua organização e
respeito e de ar por london que ela é e
se expressa em que chuta parte então sei
se vou jogar vamos ver andando pela mata
viva e obviamente muito obrigado